22 years ago uh in
in may i did 10 days of hard work i
didn't sleep much
but um before that in february i was
recruited
um my friends said you know
come out to the coast we'll have a few
laughs do scheme in the browser
and by the time i got there of course it
was supposed to look like java and as
kristoff said b
a little language i knew after i got
into the netscape 2 that it would either
die quickly and microsoft would
completely replace it
or it would be around for 20 or years or
longer and i said this to my cubicle
mate at netscape jeff weinstein so he
can
testify to that but people get impatient
and they get tempted by things like you
know
windows on the pc and you think the web
will die every 10 years and it
doesn't it just keeps going and that's
why i like this quote from ian hickson
things that are impossible just take
longer i'm going to cover why that is
necessarily so with the web and the best
way to cope with that fact
um i've been around a long time so there
was netscape
javascript i found in mozilla with jamie
zwinski and other people
did firefox which restarted the browser
market nobody thought that was possible
taught google how to do chrome and for
me the interesting innovation is now
going into peer-to-peer networks that
are not just for
downloading songs but but now for things
like
cryptocurrencies and um involved in
those as well as in uh
ad blocking tracking protection and
privacy by design
i think privacy tech is going to be big
in the next 10 years i'm glad that
europe is doing its part there
how do we cope with the fact that in any
regime of web browsers you're going to
have
competition you might have a near-death
experience where
internet explorer takes 95 of the market
but firefox showed how to restart it and
i think that will
be a lesson that is not forgotten that
means you'll have competing browsers
working in standards bodies
and they have to find a modis vivendi
they have to get along and
the best way that i've learned to do it
is just not smoke but to
socialize and this has been going on
with
javascript since 1996 november when
netscape took javascript to the ecma
standards body at that time it was the
european computer manufacturers
association
uh here's the secretary general of the
time of bon vivant i remember fondly
he's retired now he lived in geneva
he has a dutch surname but he's belgian
born
polymath uh reconcile
really fun guy um and that i think
taught me something that
we've tried to keep going in this
committee that you have dinners together
and you you try not to hold grudges or
let personality conflicts which are
inevitable get the better of you
um and and netscape while it lasted did
that
and microsoft even played relatively
fair as they took the browser market
but then they shut it all down so with
firefox we brought it back
and we actually restarted it i went to
geneva in 2005
after firefox 1 0 came out in november
of 2004
and i said the on let's let's bring the
band back together it's time to improve
javascript again
and you know microsoft was kind of like
oh do we really have to
we're doing c sharp but macromedia had
used a version of javascript called
actionscript in the flash player and so
we formed an alliance with them
and this led to a bunch of learning and
socializing and philosophizing that i
think is important i use this
famous painting by raphael there's a
detail from it
um that's doug crockford on the left and
me on the right
doug's always pointing up and i'm like
keep it real um
there are bad problems in committees
it's inevitable because you get um
conflicts of personality and conflicts
of style and and sort of
deep deeply held beliefs that aren't
fully unpacked into chains of
reasoning it's hard to reason together
if people come from
really different schools of thought so
we've learned how to cope with this by
not rushing to any conclusion when
you're doing language design you're
solving many problems which
cross cut or trade off against each
other you have to take the
the hermeneutic spiral
as it's called you have to be willing to
go around
several times before you close on a
design and sometimes you have to throw
things out and start over again that's
happened
for instance with es6 proxies you have
to avoid the temptation to say
well i have developers that are solving
this complex
compound problem so i'm just going to
give them a complex compound solution
that's kind of a fixed
composite function because that usually
doesn't work it's usually
the case that when you decompose it you
find that you've got
uncomposable parts and what we'd rather
do is what the scheme
scheme in the browser the scheme uh
report says in its very first paragraph
it says
break the language down into orthogonal
primitives that work well together
so that's been the job of the committee
and coming to an understanding of those
primitives and
minimizing the choice of primitives
choice of axioms has been important
then there's the ugly i shouldn't linger
on it
tuko you find
people sometimes let their competitive
interests get the better of them and so
they use um essentially bad faith
arguing they find
sort of vague um excuses for not doing
something and
they all have some truth in them they're
all half truths you ain't gonna need it
don't scare the junior people you know
don't make it into java but you have to
actually get into the
concrete aspects to get past those
objections because that could be true of
many things that we want
and while we don't want to make
javascript into java languages grow
there's a great
talk by guy steele where he starts with
a subset of the english language in
presenting the talk and then he grows
his subset as he gives the talk
languages grow that's how they how they
progress um
so we've had to cope with the good the
bad and the ugly and we've made progress
the old days were when netscape had some
market power which was going away and we
got
es1 done based on my work in netscape 2
and 3. ecmascript 2 just
historical curiosity was the iso version
of es1 es3 was the big one it had a
bunch of new things it had fully nested
functions and closures function
expressions
a lot of you may have heard about es4 i
spent many years on that that's where we
with macromedia which got bought by
adobe tried to really get
microsoft to sit up and pay attention by
doing the big language that
had been envisioned even in 1999 uh by
somebody named walmart horwat
of netscape who i gave the keys to the
kingdom too and he designed this
language
action swift 3 has a lot of aspects of
it
it actually got implemented by microsoft
on the server side in 2000 but they
never promoted it and
did not standardize it es4 failed but
the failure was important because the
committee
then with my code name harmony found a
way to
come together and work on es5 which was
the
no new syntax 3.1 kind of
incremental step from es3 that had been
started concurrently with the s4
doug crockford and others dissenting
from es4 in public
we pulled everybody together and we've
been operating in much better mode since
then es6 obviously is a big leap forward
a lot of backlog had to be absorbed
but uh now we've got on to a better
cadence uh there's a backstory
some of this is you've heard about
scheme in the browser
it was a lie uh it was a vain hope let's
say
um there were other things that i did in
hurry in the 90s that i do regret
you know do while switch try catch
that's all okay i think that worked out
um
regular expressions uh thought to demu i
based on
pro 4 sorry i met larry wall in 97 and i
said hey i'm putting pro regular
expressions in javascript and he turned
green he looked very unhappy um
he was changing them for pro 5. uh and
pro 6 is even even
different because he had could do a
clean slate language um
the restarting of of tc39 i mentioned
that that was painful because microsoft
didn't want to do much to the language
until they did and when they did it was
still this sort of
half-hearted thing until i think chrome
came out and that really woke them up
so um we we had you know amazing
performance work in javascript engines
uh we even had
um google say that javascript cannot be
repaired so we'll do
dash now dart and i told him it wouldn't
work they didn't listen
uh that actually leaked through
an accidental global message uh post
by somebody on the tc39 committee whose
name is on it he's not the author of
that dash memo but he
he turned white and went over to another
googler during the november
2010 meeting and tapped them on the
shoulder in theatrical fashion and they
all all the googlers decamped to the
hall
and we said what's going on is the
singularity arrived has
has sergey or larry cancelled free you
know cookies
um only later did we learn that
my friend on the committee from google
had accidentally posted this this
internal memo
which javascript must be replaced it was
like we love javascript
but it must be replaced and it's just
really hard to replace there's something
like successful um dna about javascript
once it's in there you're kind of hard
they're getting rid of it
another thing i'm particularly proud of
in the last ten years was this sort of
discovery
carving nature at the joint as plato
said of science
of asim.js inside of javascript
if you look at c code and some of you
probably know c code you have
you have a statically typed language
with machine types and
there is fast c code notably games games
are always
torturing the hardware can you map that
to javascript it turns out you can and
this was discovered
first i think by elon zakai maybe by
others concurrently or a little bit
before
at adobe labs and the trick is to use
the bitwise operators that i put in
most of them come from c one of them
comes from java so i'm really glad i put
those
those like vertical bar operator in
because that
if it hadn't been in there from 1995 it
would have been hard to add later
and the fact that it was there all along
meant we could do
incredibly fast javascript also needed
typed arrays from webgl
and this is this is not meant for
reading but just the dynamic nature of
javascript has led to a common
architecture in
all i think all the top engines now the
open source engines where you have
interpreting and you have sort of a fast
just-in-time compiler
baseline compiler and then you have a
much more aggressive
compiler that operates when there's
really hot code running
and the fast subset of javascript that
is asm.js the statically typed fast
subset
allows bypassing the baseline jit and
the interpreter
which has paved the way for webassembly
which we're all excited about
a little more back story i i realized um
after alan where's brock did a great job
uh as editor of atlanta 262
and as we got es5 done
that he was not happy at microsoft so i
recruited him to mozilla and we did es6
that was a
a coup and i was uh glad to have alan on
the crew at mozilla there
the formalization of asm.js as a type
system was by dave herman the
exploratory compiler driven work was by
elon zakai and luke wagner did the
amazing compiler
that bypasses those jits and does a sort
of whole module compilation to machine
code
and it all came together in one week in
the fall of 2012
in raleigh north carolina epic
games unreal engine 3 was ported in four
days
you know you had to get the audio
working using open el
map2 web audio you had to get opengl map
to webgl
fix a few compiler boxes suddenly this
game is running at 60 frames a second
tim sweeney the founder of epic said he
thought it would take years to get there
i think this pretty much killed portable
native client and other such approaches
it was at that point inevitable that web
assembly would emerge
babel.js was interesting because 10 or
20 years ago
people would say i'm never writing code
with a compiler i'm writing javascript
to the metal
and and now they've gotten used to using
tools and i think that's beneficial
linting but even type systems type
script and so on
and at some point i think the committee
will standardize some kind of type
system we have a new proposal from some
folks at google
it's going to take a while it there's
disagreement between flow and typescript
and there's
a lot of evolution and exploration to do
you know how modern software works on a
rapid release cycle like six-week cycle
for
you know firefox chrome brave um
some of their browsers are more like an
annual cycle the ecma committee is now
going on an annual cadence which is good
because
it gets rid of that scheduled chicken
problem where if people feel like
they're going to miss
they can just go to the next year they
don't try to hold up everything to jam
and something doesn't fit
um and and as predicted google threw in
the towel on dart
and around the same time i think threw
in the towel on portable native client
was not going to go across browser you
know webassembly was out in 2015
june so there's been a lot of
interesting backstory that you may not
hear everywhere i sometimes try to share
this this is at a brooklyn js meetup
where i said
you know some things changed some say
the same
apple is still apple other companies
sort of trade roles and
and attitudes and and right after that
of course microsoft open source their
chakra core
javascript engine we're still waiting
for edge but it could happen
it was a good move um i'll just share
in detail one of the new things that's
coming into um es 2018 or something i
don't know what it'll be
it's it's getting implemented in all the
engines now uh all the open source
engines
and that's big and you know how when you
start counting up
in javascript you get past 53-bit
integer you lose precision
i didn't have time to do any other
number types and i did put in those
bitwise operators so
implicit in javascript are 32-bit signed
in unsigned integers
other than that you're out of luck and
if you want to go to really big numbers
like the finance people do you end up
using your own
big decimal or big integer library but
we're putting big end into the language
and it will have nice
end suffix for literal syntax they'll
have operators that work sensibly
even with some safe conversions for
comparisons it will have the ability to
name property keys and cast
to narrow or integer types which is
important for asm.js because bigint will
matter there
this is how we're going to project
64-bit types
uh through javascript big-ins back into
64-bit machine types in azim js
i i had to get this ball rolling by
saying let's do 64-bit types and a
couple of people
um dan ehrenberg notably um
said let's let's let's do big ends and
we can make it just as fast it'll be
better
and dart had big in so we know it's
better so that's good um
i'll put these slides as you can see the
links here's an example fibonacci
function in javascript nicely using
uh destructuring and computing fibonacci
numbers
and if you go up to fib 79 you run out
of 53 bits of mantissa and ieee double
everyone blames me for for ieee's
floating point problems like not a
number
somebody put a tweet up with a
oscilloscope with not a number
this is like a tektronix or hp
oscilloscope and they said it's
javascript and i said no it's not
it's c code it's it's um it's ieee but
i'll take the blame
with bigint we get rid of this we get
the true answer
uh in green instead of the wrong one
ready
just to show you that the committee is
is not messing around these are a
selection of the stage three proposals
those union node realize import as a
function is hard to do
statically but it's coming thanks to
dominic google
dominic danikola so dynamic import
pretty big
michael fitcar is championing flat map
and flattenings for all the functional
fans out there
seb martin at facebook is doing um
rest and spread for objects that's what
the third line shows
we're evolving classes and uh actually i
think other things to have private
fields and methods and and
the design is more like ruby i think um
there's still some details being debated
there but this is at stage three
uh synchronous iterations so you can do
for a weight of
and you can totally efface the the pain
of promises
a bunch of regular expression fixes look
behind back in 1997 just missed
es3 it was just being added to pearl
when we were cutting off the es3
regular expression features so finally
getting a look behind assertions
and unicode is getting help and named
property groups
uh the slash s flag on regular
expressions and there's there's much
more
small proposals some bigger ones i
didn't cover here
they all have to go through a rigorous
process to get into the next version
language but
in the annual cycle we're going at
javascript will continue to evolve
and that's why i say always bet on js
and
i have to treat webassembly fairly
because it's another input language for
the same javascript vm that we all enjoy
in multiple
browsers and oh yeah webpack's pretty
cool too thank you very much